In this lesson, we've discussed some of the basic skills
necessary to make an effective
information visualization. We've talked about some
of the best ways to visually encode data, and also
some of the most effective methods for charting different types of
data. We've also gone over the basics of making visualizations
in Python. If you find the individualization really interesting, I'd strongly
encourage you to look at some blogs or websites that
aggregate some of the most interesting data visualizations. It's not hard
to find them. Just go to Google, type in data visualization, and you'll come
across some really interesting stuff. You'll use
this new found data visualization know how to
make some really interesting graphics that communicate
our findings so far about subway ridership in
New York City. I'll be really interested to see what you guys come up with.